on the mound for the royals making his
fourth start
the rookie our 2018 first round draft
choice from the university of florida
brady singer just keeps getting better
every single time out
and he gets a swing and a miss and
strikes out kepler
so that is 19 strikeouts now in not even
16 innings by the rookie and i'll tell
you what now
that strike weight is 71 percent on his
fastballs but there's the change
same thing here just try to challenge
him away middle and he knows what to do
with
hits into left field gordon lays out and
makes an
outstanding catch alex gordon gold
glover
he wants another one are you kidding
that glove he wears
is a magnet for the ball jose barrios
looking for his second win
of the season pitch well his last
timeout and this is his 14th
career start against the royals dozier
was one of the american league leaders
last year with 27 go ahead rbis
and look what he does goes to the
opposite field
and comes merrifield in comes solaire
welcome back hunter dozier taking what
he gave him he knew that
carrillos wasn't going to challenge him
with anything in
middle end but he stayed away from him
and dozier
a pitch in the middle waited on him he
saw that hole and just
one easy swing of the bat and he's back
that's one of the reasons why he's
the bulldozer he's not here now for
kepler with two men aboard and one out
kepler went down swinging
to start the ball game and the one-two
pitch a line drive into right that's a
base hit that's going to one-up and find
the wall
hits off the base of the wall buxton
scores avila to third he'll be held
an rbi double for kepler and the twins
are down by one a 2-1 game
so kepler with his 12th rbi a line drive
missile turning out a fastball at 94
that was
in and he ripped it to right no chance
for solaire
as it hit the grass then found the base
of the wall and the twins are down by
one second and third one out milanko
hitting 320 this year with two strikes
second highest average in all the
baseball
off the end of the bat the tying run
will score and polanco
is retired at first avila scores it's
two a piece and
polanco hustling down the line made that
a very close play
well modesty must have shifted back
towards his regular position because he
was playing up the middle here's the
circle change
again left out over and right off the
end of the bat so we're tied up
jorge solaire he hit some monsters last
night he's a strong
man fizz whit goes pitches swung on roll
to the right side and through
the score how about that oh man so
that's hitting them where they ain't
oh he wins the battle with a squibber
you look up scribber in the dictionary
they'll show this video
highlight right here the booty falls out
that's called a booty knock
oh yeah you couldn't roll it any better
and whit the pressure was on he probably
could have scored but there's no need to
with nobody out no matter how many runs
they get this inning i hope the royals
get a bunch
that's the key at bat of the inning so
here's salvador perez
hits it well right field kepler it'll be
deep enough
solaire is going to tag as well wit
comes home
and the royals are back in front at
three to two and
perez does get the quality a b
nicely done by salvador perez picking up
nut rbi number nine on the season and a
fastball that's down
he didn't try to hook it or pull it went
the other way with it singer back on top
95 pitch day for brady singer as he
worked five innings he runs on five hits
nice job he's a competitive player he's
tough as dale yeah
michael bronco will lead things off
barrios has thrown 87
pitches the royals trying to make it
uncomfortable for him
there's a drive way back and
that's a goner home run michael franco
well when he stepped in the box you said
maybe he could milk
burrills and get him out of the this uh
game here for sure he's at the end of
his rope
three and two he comes in and try to
challenge him and
you can't stick a piece of cheese by a
hungry rat he barrels it
and state fair kept his hands in enough
to where the top hand didn't dominate
and hook the pole
that's a beautiful lead off homer just
went deep for the fourth time this year
and the royals have a 4-2 lead
josh daemon comes out for the seventh
inning and he did a terrific job
striking out two batters in the seventh
friday before being taken out as a
precautionary measure
they'll face buxton right away wow
holy smokes he made quick work of buxton
that was
impressive now the batter is polanco
he's well he manicured that at bad
nicely
and in the inning he strikes out a pair
the royals hold their four to two lead
going to the bottom of the seven stomach
trying to go this
eighth inning yeah i like it matheny
saying hey look you look so good that
last inning why not get me three more
outs here
get it to our closer the o2 pitch
in there strike three called two
brilliant
innings by josh dahman who is this guy
man he's come out of nowhere barlow will
close to you
this afternoon want to put any added
pressure on yourself you got a two-run
lead here
try not to give many free passes the
one-two
in their strike three call the royals
get the sweep
of the american league central champion
minnesota twins
scotty boy way to go and the bulldozers
back
how about it these guys are fired up and
you can't go
into an off day tomorrow better than
this royals on a nice run
everything's working fizz you talked
about the pin to win
outstanding job brady singer
congratulations
on your first big league win this is a
beauty sweep
the twinkies